you tweeted quote why does chemistry
need a universal programming language
question mark
for all the reasons you can think of
reliability interoperability
collaboration remove ambiguity lower
cost increase safety open up discovery
molecular customization and publication
of executable chemical code
which is fascinating by the way just
publish code
and um
can you maybe elaborate a little bit
more about this kai dl
what does the universal language of
chemistry look like
a crone and
complete language it's a true incomplete
language really it's um but um so what
it has it has a series of
operators in it like add
heat stir
um
so there's a bunch of just unit
operations and all it is really is just
uh
it's with chemical engineers when i
talked about this that you've just re
you've just you've just rediscovered
chemical engineering and i said well
yeah i know i said well
that's you know that's trivial i said
well well not real well yes it is
trivial and that's why it's good because
we've not only have we just got
rediscovered chemical engineering we've
made it implementable on universal
hardware that doesn't cost very much
money
and so the kdl has a series of
statements like define the reactor so it
defines
the reagents so they're all labels so
you assign them
and what we i also implement at the
beginning is because i give all the
hardware i p address you put it on a
graph
and so what it does is like the graph is
equivalent to the the process of
firmware
then the processor code so when you take
your kdl
and you go to run it on your computer
you can run it on any compatible
hardware in any configuration says
what's your what's your graph look like
as long as i can solve the problem on
the graph with these unit operations you
have the resources available compile
chem piles
[Laughter]
all right we can carry on for years but
it is really it's compilation
and what it now does is it says okay the
problem we have before is it was
possible to do robotics for chemistry
but the robots were really expensive
they were unique they had they were
vendor locked and what i want to do is
to make sure that every chemist in the
world can get access to machinery like
this at virtually no cost because it
makes it safer
it makes it more reliable and then if
you go to the literature and you find a
molecule that could potentially cure
cancer
and let's say the molecule that could
potentially cure cancer takes you three
years to repeat
and maybe a student finishes their phd
in the time and they never get it back
um so it's really hard to
to kind of get all the way to that
molecule and it limits the ability of
humanity to build on it
if they just download the code and can
execute it
it turns
i would say the electronic laboratory
notebook in chemistry is a data
symmetry
because no one will ever reproduce it
for now the data cemetery is a jupiter
notebook and you can just execute it and
people can play with it yeah the access
to it reverses the magnitude
is increased
uh we'll talk about the so as with all
technologies i think there's way more
exciting possibilities but there are
also terrifying possibilities and we'll
talk about all of them but let me just
kind of linger on the machine learning
side of this so you're describing
programming but
it's a language i don't know if you've
heard about open air codex which is uh
yeah i'm playing with it he's playing
of course you are
you really are rick from rick and morty
this is great okay uh
except philosophically d i mean he is i
guess kind of philosophically deep too
so for people who don't know gpt dpt3
that's the language model that can do
natural language generation so you can
give it a prompt and it can complete the
rest of it but it turns out that that
kind of prompt it's not just completes
the rest of it's generating
uh
like novel sounding text and then you
can apply that to generation of other
kinds of stuff
uh so these kinds of uh transformer
based language models are really good at
forming at uh forming deep
representations
of a particular space of like a medium
like language so you can then apply it
to a specific substance language like
programming
so you can have it
learn the representation of the python
programming language and use it to then
generate
uh syntactically and semantically
correct
uh programs so you can start to make
progress on one of the hardest problems
in computer science which is program
synthesis how do you write programs that
accomplish different tasks
so what uh
openai codex does is it generate those
programs based on a
a prompt of some kind usually you can do
a natural language prompt so basically
as you do when you program you write
some
a comment which serves the basic
documentation of the inputs and the
outputs and the function of the
particular set of code and it's able to
generate that
point being is you can generate programs
using machine learning using neural
networks
those programs operate on the boring old
computer
can you generate programs that operate
there's got to be a clever version of
programs for this but uh can you write
programs that uh operate on a computer
yep there's actually software out there
right now we can go and do it
right so yeah it's a heuristic it's
rule-based
but we have
what we've done
inspired by
codex actually
is um over the summer i ran a little
workshop some of my groups got this
inspired idea that we should get a load
of
um our students and ask them to manually
collect data to label
chemical procedures into kdl
and
um we have a thing called synthreader so
that so there's a bunch of people doing
this right now but they're doing it
without
uh abstraction
and because we have an abstraction
that's implementable in the hardware
um we've developed basically a chemical
analog of codecs
what you're going to say we say sergeant
trouble when you say abstraction in the
hardware what do you mean so right now a
lot of people doing machine learning and
reading chemistry and just and saying oh
you've all these operations add shake
whatever he
but they but because they don't have a
uniform um i mean there's a couple of
groups doing it competitors actually and
they're good very good
but um
they can't run that code automatically
it they are losing
meaning
and and with and the really important
thing that you have to do is generate
context
and so what we've learned to do with our
abstraction is make sure we can pull the
context out of the text
and so
can we take
a chemical procedure and read it and
generate our executable code yes
what's the hardest part about the whole
pipeline from the initial text
interpreting the initial text of a paper
extracting the meaningful context and
the meaningful chemical information to
then generating the the program to then
uh running that program in the hardware
what's what's the hardest part about
that pipeline as we look towards a
universal touring computer so the
hardest computer the heart the hardest
thing with the
the pipeline is that um
the software
the model gets confused
between some meanings right so if
you know chemists are very good at
inventing words that aren't broken down
so i would the classic word that you
would use for boiling something is
called reflux so reflux is um you would
have a salt you'd have a solvent in a
round bond flask at reflux it would be
boiling going up the reflux condenser
and coming down but that term reflux to
reflux could be changed you know to
people often make up words
new words and the and then the software
can fall over but what we've been able
to do is a bit like in python
or any programming language is identify
when things aren't matched so you
present the code you say this isn't
matched you may want to think about this
and then the user goes and says oh i
mean reflux and just ticks the box and
collects it so what what the codex or
the chemex
uh
does in this case
is it just it
suggests the first go
and then the chemist goes and corrects
it and i really want the chemist to
correct it because
it's not safe i believe for for to allow
ai to just read literature and generate
code at this stage because now you're
having actual by the way chemex nice
uh
nice name uh
so you you are unlike
which is fascinating
if we live in a fascinating moment in
human history but yes you're
literally connecting ai
to some
physical
and
like it's building something in the
physical realm yeah especially in the
space of chemistry
that operates sort of
invisibly yeah
yeah i would say that's right
and it's it's really important to
understand those labeling schemes right
and one of the things i was never i was
always worried about the beginning that
the abstraction was going to fall over
and the way we did it was just by brute
force to start with we just kept reading
the literature and saying is there
anything new can we add a new rule in
and actually our kydl language expand
exploded
there are so many extra things we had to
keep adding and then i realized the
primitives still were maintained and i
could break them down again so
we get it's pretty good i mean there are
problems they're problems of you know
interpreting any big sentence and
turning it into an actionable code and
then codex is not without its problems
you can you can crash it quite easily
right you can generate nonsense but boy
it's interesting i would love to learn
to program now using codex
right just hacking around right and i
wonder if chemists in the future will
learn to
do chemistry by just hacking around with
the system writing in different things
because the key thing that we're doing
with the chemistry is that where a lot
of mathematical chemistry went wrong is
people
and i think wolfram does this in
mathematica he assumes
that chemistry is a reaction where atom
a or molecule a reacts with molecule b
to give molecule c that's not what
chemistry is
chemistry is take take some molecule
take a liquid and a solid
mix it up and heat it
and then extract it
so the programming language is actually
with respect to the process operations
and if you flick in process space
not in chemical graph space
you unlock everything because there's
only a finite number of processes you
need to do in chemistry
and that yeah and that's reassuring and
so so we're in the middle of it it's
really exciting um
it's not you know the bill on the end or
and there is like i say errors that can
creep in one day we might be able to do
it without human interaction you
simulate it and you'll know enough about
the simulation that will it the you know
i'm the lab won't catch fire
you